all right your question is it garbage if
your dad goes through the trash and
convinces you to reuse tissues that are
still good holy [ __ ]
security
[Applause]
god damn
what are they charging for a rolling
toilet paper up in this [ __ ] i
mean i know there's supply chain issues
but god damn
he did this all when you were growing up
i assume
yeah like once a week when we took out
the trash
but what's not good to do what like to
blow your nose again or
first of all tissues aren't expensive
i mean i don't know how bad like
homeless people can get tissues it's not
like
you know it's not like yeah it's a
cadillac you're throwing out or
something it's tissues holy [ __ ] can i
can i ask something here please would
there be a progression like if you blew
your nose in it that means that tissue
was then good enough was there a set of
rules wipe your ass with or something
[Music]
your dad's weird what the [ __ ]
monitored what are you 11 this is
[ __ ] stranger things
and i have a i have a strong suspicion
these weren't kleenex we were talking
about either
just brown paper bags
[Laughter]
what'd your dad do for a living
she goes oh there you go like that's a
known trait of engineers
classic engineers
taking through the trash reusing tissues
i've seen it once i've seen it a
thousand times
i hear pilots freak out about paper
towels too
what are you doing
clapping up for leanne that's [ __ ]
fantastic yeah i like that one
i like that one
okay where's jake h
okay i'm sorry jake yeah
so you guys hold on let's act like i was
next to you when you sent it let's let's
just start here on the background check
do you other guys do two other guys do
you both have email
and we got we got to be thorough
you're putting jet skis in [ __ ]
hatchbacks i'm sorry
he's like you have to do our job we have
to be thorough with this i do have a
gmail but i'm out of data right
jeez is really [ __ ] me
at midnight i can check my emails
you guys both have email
all right very cool have you ever walked
into a room and your cousin looks a
little too good
[Applause]
[Applause]
i didn't know exactly what you're
talking about yeah
when did you walk into this room
oh no it was thanksgiving 98.
[ __ ] dirt bag
see now he's coming down he's telling
that you visit you chad acting you made
it up you're like i haven't seen her in
a while what am i supposed to do she's
technically not my cousin she's married
so
she's really my sister tactically
god damn well give it one time for jake
guys
or i'm sorry aaron not jake jake i
apologize that i publicly put that on
you
that's real aaron [ __ ] right there